foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
yeah
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] em
[Music]
welcome back
the Tony Michaels podcast
from our New Year's break it is Tuesday
January 3rd and Kevin McCarthy still
does not have 218 boots
this is gonna go well past the first
ballot there's no question
Uh Kevin McCarthy is the loser leader of
the loser party they're a fraud party to
be frank
the party up front listen
everyone is wondering why this morning
all the great media pundits out there
are wondering why this morning Kevin
McCarthy doesn't have the votes
there's one person that is responsible
for this only one that is responsible
for what is going what we are going to
watch happen live today on the floor of
the House of Representatives
only one
Donald J Trump that is who is
responsible for this
frankly he is the engineer of what is
going to happen of the chaos that is
going to happen today
it is my belief
that Donald Trump is causing all this
division intentionally
he's getting Marjorie Taylor green to
support Kevin McCarthy he's getting
Biggs and bobert to go and gets to go
against McCarthy
he needs someone to blame I don't know
if you've paid attention to his fraud
Social account over the last 24 hours
you probably haven't
but Grandpa Poopypants the Cheeto desk
you and honor
it's still talking about how it's not
his fault
in the 2022 midterms
well if they're voting for a speaker for
the majority of the house today wouldn't
you consider that a win it's not a win
for them the reason why is because
number one they do not know how to
govern they don't know how to do it
number two they have no real leaders
they're not policy makers they are chaos
makers that is what they do
Democrats elect policy makers some chaos
members
Republicans have NADA zero zilch policy
makers they are all all of them every
last [ __ ] one of them if yours in our
next to your name you are a fraud and a
chaos maker
that is what you are
you are part of the America First Nazi
party
and you will and will not and cannot do
anything but lose
and we should be here for it this
morning you should be cheering for
democracy you are watching the the
political party that wants to tear down
our democracy not be able to function
inside of it
the scene this morning at the Capitol
some people are going to say oh this is
bad for our democracy this is bad for
our country no it is not
it is not bad for our country it is not
bad for our democracy to watch the one
party who wants to tear it down who
wants to get rid of it not be able to
operate inside of it
they keep doing interviews
of constituents and New York stirred
that voted for George Santos and they're
completely disappointed that they were
duped and and defrauded of their vote
it's not just you in New York's third
it's in every [ __ ] District that
voted for republicans
they're all frauds George Santos just as
an amateur at being a [ __ ] liar
foreign
Ted Cruz Jim Jordan Donald Trump Matt
gatz Lauren bobert
Dan Crenshaw Andy Biggs Kevin McCarthy
Mitch McConnell
the list goes on and on they're
professionals George Santos you're an
amateur that's the difference
you have it you made it to the big
league without having the talent my
friend
you're just not that great at hiding
your lies and stacking your lives on top
of each other you're just not that good
at it
other Republicans are much better
but today today we get to see right out
in the open how inept
how disorganized
how ununited the Republican Party really
is and again it's one person at the
heart of this only one that is
responsible for what is going to happen
on the house floor today
Donald Trump
why do you think he backed Kevin
McCarthy he backed Kevin McCarthy so he
if Kevin McCarthy gets to 218 or
receives enough votes to become speaker
either way depending on if people vote
present or not depending on how many
ballots we go to
he picked him so he could say I picked
the winner
and if Kevin McCarthy doesn't get the
votes today
Donald Trump isn't gonna blame it on
himself he's gonna blame it on Kevin
McCarthy just like he's blaming the
midterms on pro-life Republicans now
and that was his that was his [ __ ]
delusional deranged rant over the
weekend
that somehow it was the pro-life
Republicans that lost them the 2022
midterms no it is your entire party and
it is you as the leader of the party
that that made it to where there was no
Red Wave because this country doesn't
[ __ ] like you we don't want
authoritarianism we don't want it
you can [ __ ] off with that [ __ ]
and you can gerrymandered districts all
you want to try to win a a four-seat
majority in the house but now Kevin
McCarthy is Reliant Reliant
upon George Santos
the most obvious [ __ ] fraud that's
ever been
sworn into Congress he's gonna swear him
in just so he'll vote for him
if Kevin McCarthy gets the votes today I
don't know how many ballots he's not
going to get in on this first ballot now
I don't know if you watch some of the
clips and maybe we'll we'll be able to
pull him up here uh Biggs and bobert and
basically Kevin McCarthy uh canceled all
concessions that he made to his
speakership he finally realized what I
was saying was true
he finally realized it he if he would
just come watch my fi if half these
[ __ ] would just come listen to
this show they would know what is gonna
happen
I said weeks ago that Kevin McCarthy was
gonna have to trade away his entire
speakership
the entirety he wasn't gonna actually be
speaker he was just going to be sitting
in the office the caucus was going to be
the speaker
he finally realized that apparently
sometime this morning and I guess he got
into a a cursing match with some of the
members
that's the word
I'm here for it folks
listen this
is exactly
what our democracy needs
our democracy needs a transparent visual
of why the Republican Party In This
Moment In This timeline right now in
history cannot be cannot
have their hands on our government
National the house the Senate the
executive branch they can't be held they
cannot you cannot count on them as
Governors attorney generals secretaries
of States state legislators County
Executives you can't count on them
they are authoritarians they are the
America First Nazi party
and not only that
they are ninkapoop Nazis nincompoops
they do not know how to govern usually
authoritarians don't
this is a thing that happens
authoritarians are really shitty at
governing
especially ones trying to to place an
authoritarian in power their entire
mindset is only for that authoritarian
sound familiar sounds like a cult
doesn't it
but this morning you should be cheering
this and I know pundits are going to say
oh well this is this is damaging to our
history this is damaging to our
democracy listen listen to me
they are full of [ __ ] [ __ ]
absolute full of [ __ ] [ __ ]
don't let anyone convince you that the
gears of our democracy are bad for our
democracy
that somehow they send a bad signal well
listen the bad signal needs to be sent
this country needs to see that the
Republican party is inept
they cannot be responsible of anything
at this point in history they are
worthless
frankly they want to destroy our
democracy that's why democracy is
destroying them I told you the entire
year
that democracy is their enemy and today
you are going to watch it play out just
as I have described it
they can't function
inside of this democracy of this
Republic because they don't believe in
it they don't want it
thank you
these are the reasons why
and not only that it's only there it is
only their power that they care about
that's why they've turned authoritarian
their power over over other people
rather it be the lgbtq community telling
them what the [ __ ] they can and can't do
the bycat pot Community tell them what
the [ __ ] they can and can't do women
telling them what the hell they can and
can't do
it's always about their power always
and today you're gonna see how powerless
they truly are even when they have a
majority folks
it's been a hundred years hundred
[ __ ] years
since a speaker had to go past one
ballot the reason why this is so
important
for the American people to see how the
Republican Party cannot govern
so that we don't put them
in a position to be responsible for
governing and policy making
is that for a hundred years
the Speaker of the House
their main job
their main job
is to count votes folks
they even assign a whip to make sure
those votes are whipped to get the count
that they need that is their main job
Kevin McCarthy has already failed at his
very first vote count this is very
important
and we must as proton as the
pro-democracy Coalition politicize this
at every single step
and we must lay it at the feet of one
[ __ ] because there is one
[ __ ] that is responsible
the Republican party is not a party
anymore
it is not
how long has my sound been off
it's been out the whole time
oh my gosh
oh boy
what a rant
lost
by a muted mic
oh
thank you for letting me know that my
mic was muted
this
is
the way democracy works
this is the way that we need democracy
to work
we have to politicize
that the Republican Party absolutely can
not govern at every step
mark my words I don't know how many
votes it'll take
3 12.
20. hell we may go two or three weeks
without a Speaker of the House
and this is what Donald Trump wants by
the way because he is responsible for
all this again Donald Trump is on the
phone with these four or five members
that are absolutely not going to vote
for Kevin McCarthy
every single day telling them whipping
them getting people to whip them into
frenzies not to vote for Kevin McCarthy
all the while
getting members
to vote for Kevin McCarthy
to whip people into a frenzy to get
these four members to vote for McCarthy
and tell McCarthy bows at his feet
and I'm here for it folks
these nincompoop Nazis
that are tearing themselves into shreds
it is going to be beautiful to watch
again this is why we said the
pro-democracy Coalition said all year
long you cannot put these [ __ ] idiots
in charge of the Congress you cannot put
them in charge of the House of
Representatives
their only leader
their only leader in in the America
First Nazi party anymore is the cult
leader
Donald Trump
that's why I believe he's going to be
their nominee I don't care what
indictments come what the news is rather
he defends off a try or not that
[ __ ] is going to be their
nominee because today you will watch
these idiots bow at his feet
on the house floor
as they vote with their constituents
permission on the floor
first
third in line to the presidency mind you
and they won't be able to pull it
together
not even not I I don't know how many
again I don't know how many ballots
definitely not for at least two or three
I don't believe
I mean Kevin McCarthy just came out in
front of a microphone not too long ago
basically saying Matt Getz once Hakeem
Jeffries to be the speaker
the reason why Kevin McCarthy says that
Matt gatz wants Hakeem Jeffries to be
the speaker is because folks there's
Republicans that are willing
they are willing there's a few of them
handfuls of them not very many but there
are some of them that are considering
having a leader who can lead the house
as opposed to someone who is absolutely
sold out to the Cheeto dust cue in honor
why do you think all the chaos all the
chaos is so Donald Trump can can
guarantee that Kevin McCarthy has to
genuflect in front of him at every move
at every step
and Kevin McCarthy is a loser I don't
know if you know this
Kevin McCarthy is a [ __ ] loser
he ran unopposed for the speakership
and couldn't win
they had to beg
beg Paul Ryan
to be the speaker because Kevin McCarthy
is such a loser why do you think Donald
Trump wants him to be speaker
what better speaker to have for a loser
than a loser like Kevin McCarthy
he wants him as an excuse as a foil
that's what he wants
he needs someone
in the house to blame
when they fail and they're oh they're
gonna fall they're gonna [ __ ] face oh
my God they're gonna fail oh [ __ ] are
you tired of of losing yet Republicans
holy [ __ ] you haven't even started
the 118th Congress and you're all and
you're already showing that you cannot
govern
you have no path
to getting any government business done
in September when the CR expires the
government will shut down
probably until the 119th Congress
I want the American people to expect
this
in September when the CR expires
they're gonna blame it on Kevin McCarthy
more than likely
he will take the brunt of the [ __ ] of
of the of the blame
but it'll be Donald Trump behind the
shutdown and it is likely
that we could see a government that
shuts down for more than a year
I know it sounds crazy but who the if
they can't if they can't even get enough
[ __ ] votes to pick out a leader
they have to rely on George Santos here
[ __ ] running around I mean just
just running away from reporters I don't
know if you've seen these clips holy
[ __ ] we're gonna blame them but God damn
I don't know how George Santos last more
than than 10 minutes
in congress with as much pressure that's
on him
but they need him
they gotta have the the fraud
they gotta have him
and by God as soon
as soon
as Kevin McCarthy after God knows how
many ballots
become speaker
they'll toss him to the side
and they'll expect that we the
pro-democracy Coalition is not going to
politicize the ever loving [ __ ] out of
it Hills to the no and and there's a lot
of Santos news today
but here here's the uh here's the image
from the house floor right now
as members are um
establishing voting to establish a
quorum so that they can start business
the business that is going to
um start today
is the question I guess is is how many
ballots will it take now here's how it
works real quick before we get started
because Texas Paul is going to join us
here after the break as we go to the
coverage from the house floor as they
start to vote for speaker and here's how
it's going to work they it's a Voice
vote okay so they don't have to have 218
they have to have the majority as long
as members are voting present now no
Democrat is going to vote president
because they're not going to make it
easy on these [ __ ]
there may be a few there may be a few
Republicans that vote present my guess
is is that on the first ballot though
it's going to be their protest ballot
they may protest for at least three or
four ballots Kevin McCarthy I guess got
into a screaming match with them and has
has vowed to stay on the floor and keep
the floor open for as long as he needs
to do as many votes as he needs today to
become speaker his goal is to walk away
with this without adjournment
someone said oh Galen says dead Ted Lou
brought popcorn to the house floor
listen get out of your [ __ ] popcorn
this is gonna be fantastic today we got
Texas Paul we got Gabe Sanchez and we
are going to watch the nincompoop Nazi
[ __ ] show
and you should cheer
as they do not know how to do democracy
and the reason why is because
the American people need to know
without a doubt the reason why they
shouldn't put Republicans in power of
anything
they're not policy makers
they're they're not representative of
your
of your [ __ ] values and your
principles
and your ideas
they're only in it for one [ __ ]
Ding and McCarthy Trump Santos every
single one of them is a prime example of
what it is it is only about their power
that's why they turned authoritarian
because they only care about their power
oh boy what a day to come back what a
day to come back from our break I hope
you had a great New Year's I want you to
do a couple things for me
if I could ask a favor because we're
gonna go to a breakdown we'll bring
Texas Paul they got George Santos on the
screen screen here what do you think
he's texting what do you think he's
texting you think he's texting his
lawyer
or his or his team of lawyers he's got
to have an international lawyer now he's
got to have a lawyer for his State
investigations he's definitely going to
want a a lawyer for his Federal
investigations he's yawning he didn't
get any [ __ ] sleep last night holy
[ __ ] this guy
listen I need you to do me a few favors
it's not hard and you're the best
audience in the world so I know you can
take care of this
if you're not subscribed to the YouTube
channel do it now do it now and share
this YouTube channel with your family
and your friends even your Maga family
and your friends oh get them here get
them all pissed off and riled up
also follow us on Twitter at the Tony
Michaels at Tony Michaels POD at the
Tony Michaels at I am Gabe Sanchez and
download every single episode on Apple
Spotify and Google you can also go to
store.dtonymichaels.com that's
store.dtonymichaels.com we run on your
support
and thank you for your support you're
the best audience in the world I'm so
glad to be back today
here's more images from the house floor
as we go to a break everyone stick
around
we got the Midas Mighty favorite Texas
Paul when we come back right after this
break
we'll be right back Mark
is the Tony Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
male do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard in blanket will
protect you too pardon blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your part in blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardons not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome welcome back to the show
thanks for sticking around Steve scalise
is walking around the house floor
maybe maybe trying to whip votes for
himself I don't know
Maybe
and because this is a voice vote so they
can vote I [ __ ] they can vote for Mickey
Mouse if they want Texas oh it doesn't
matter they can vote for Mickey Mouse
they can vote for Donald Trump they can
vote for whatever
character they would wish here is the uh
here's the image from the house floors
Texas ball
um we got police walking around looks
like he's uh you know back flapping here
um we know that he's the least Mikey in
the running uh for some of these voice
votes
Now Kevin McCarthy has to get a majority
of the votes Texas Paul on the floor
um and he can get votes
um for the majority of the members if
people vote present or they just don't
vote because you don't have to vote
during a Voice vote now here's Kevin
McCarthy and it's a majority of the
entire house it's not the majority
within his caucus it's right exactly
what what cause cause uh uh he was
saying it this morning
um about Matt guess that Matt gatz
wanted Hakeem Jeffries to be speaker
which I mean I don't think really it's
kind of delusional to think that that
would happen but it is a possibility as
Slim as it may be that there would be I
don't know um you know a half a dozen
Republicans actually won a leader and
vote for Hakeem Jeffries as the as the
speaker of the house so they could
actually get some stuff done and they
can avoid a government shutdown in
September because really honestly it
doesn't matter what Republican becomes
the speaker here whoever is the speaker
because Donald Trump is the one who
wants to have the power over the speaker
right that's why he's done what he's
done with Kevin McCarthy
um with the never Kevin's I guess you'd
call him and then he's gotten he's
gotten Trump supporters to support Kevin
and it's all a show this is all a
[ __ ] show it's all it's all planned
chaos just like January 6 was when they
were wanting to hang the vice president
I mean basically they might as well well
just be chanting Hank Kevin McCarthy
today because what they're trying what
Donald Trump is trying to do is position
himself to where he has control over the
House of Representatives and what I mean
by that is Shadow control
um but Kevin McCarthy this morning did
something that he should have done weeks
ago when I told him to do this was
actually tell them what their
concessions that they wanted with their
demands that the Republican caucus
wanted to he told them to [ __ ] off this
morning
I mean in so many words which he should
have done he should have done weeks ago
when I told him that was gonna happen
and people need to understand that the
the the the fight here why he's getting
so much fight from somebody like Andy
Biggs or Matt Gates or you know just you
know Marjorie Taylor green sucking his
ass and all that stuff I mean it's just
the reason that this is happening is
if the Republicans go back to trying to
participate in our government
there's no place for Matt Gates he's
like a Ted Cruz Ted Cruz does not is not
involved in legislating everybody hates
that some [ __ ] nobody's going to deal
with them you know Matt Gates is the
same way Lauren bobert my god do you
think she's going to be involved in
drafting legislation for Christ's sake
you know no they have one existence in
this government and that's to be
[ __ ]
and and and
that's what they're trying to hold on to
in the Republican Party they're like you
say Donald Trump is trying to keep the
the [ __ ] Legion
marching so that he's got a shot in the
future and it's just
they don't give a [ __ ] about the country
Tony they just don't
well I mean they they want to destroy
our democracy that's why the democracy
is destroying them I mean essentially
you know it that's just the way it's
gonna work and they're not gonna have
much uh they're not going to have much
success when they don't want to
participate in how our democracy Works
trying to make it work for them to
destroy it right because that's what
they're trying to do they're trying to
use democracy to destroy our democracy
yeah you know exactly my point that
you're you're making the exact point
that I'm trying to get out there much
more eloquently than I was is that if
the Republican party starts to
participate in democracy again these
people have no place
and they're fighting for their very
survival
because what does where does Matt Gates
have any place in a functioning
democracy what does he contribute at all
well I mean I don't know if a venmo
account qualifies as a participating and
being a good Steward of democracy but I
don't think it does
um
foreign
I rise today to nominate the gentleman
from California
America's new Republican majority
[Applause]
so you just heard uh Elise stephanic
nominee Kevin
Texas Paul the enthusiasm in the room
doesn't seem high
no it doesn't it does not it it's really
just a shame that these these they were
able to to you know although the
election was fantastic in our favor the
folks went out there and did an amazing
job it is just a shame that uh that the
Republicans are even in this position
even the with the slimmest majority that
they have it's just
go go ahead go ahead sorry I'm having
loading problems over here
here we are back to the house floor here
we go
this radical far left agenda to hold Joe
Biden accountable and to save the United
States of America
under Kevin McCarthy's leadership House
Republicans drafted a bold Vision to put
our nation back on track
our commitment to America is a promise
to the American people that this new
Republican majority will stand up for an
economy that's strong a nation that's
safe a future that's built upon and
swearing George Santos
accountable to the people
accountable to the people with the lies
and the fraud that George Santos has
told
a firefighter and a fourth generation
Californian from Kern County home to
wildcatters frontiersmen and the rights
and the worst crime rate in country's
history American Spirit
and dream big
this spirit that built our great nation
is what we need in our next speaker
Kevin McCarthy is a strong conservative
he looks nervous Texas Paul pro-life
yeah reporter of our Second Amendment
rights and he is committed to stopping
wasteful government spending and
shrinking the size of government when
Republicans last held the majority Kevin
helped to reduce domestic spending and
lower the tax burden on hard-working
American families
and cheated on his wife with a member of
the House
a crisis Kevin made sure Democrats could
no longer ignore he fought for and
succeeded in repealing the ill-advised
military covet vaccine mandate and he
stood on this very floor and spoke for a
record eight hours and 35 minutes to not
only delay the vote in the house
that ultimately defeated Joe Biden and
house Democrats dangerous build-backed
broke legislation oh my god did you
notice the difference between this and
when Nancy Pelosi was was selected
speaker
they didn't talk about Republicans when
Nancy Pelosi was selected speaker all
these people I mean she must have said
the word Democrat two dozen times
already
have only gained seats and won while
Republicans in the Senate and State
legislatures lost seats House
Republicans looks like Ronnie Jackson's
been on the sauce last night you see him
there Kevin no yeah eyes are a little
squinty there aren't they
like that last week Thursday
of listening to all Americans traveling
to nearly every District in this country
fighting for conservative values and
fighting for the people that we that are
committed to upholding them
Kevin has shown up in these communities
of every member in our conference and I
can guarantee he has shown up in the
districts of our many of our colleagues
across the aisle as well
his Relentless effort has yielded an
extraordinary new house Republican
majority that represents our cut
country's greatness from all walks of
life when the last Congress gaveled in
two years ago every new Republican
Welcome to our conference was a woman
veteran yeah under Kevin McCarthy we
pissed on the Red Wave is the most
diverse Republican conference in our
nation's history
foreign
[Applause]
to so many of us a proud conservative
with a tireless work ethic Kevin
McCarthy has earned the speakership of
the people's house
Madam clerk as the chair of the
Republican conference it is my high
honor to present our conference's
nominee for election to the office of
speaker of the people's house The
Honorable Kevin McCarthy from the state
of California and I yield back
I tell you the fact that this is Elisa
phonic doing this is just perfect oh
it's just perfect the you know the the
lady that brought us George Santos is
bringing us Kevin you're great no [ __ ]
no [ __ ] well that's just hilarious well
the other thing too is me you know you
think there's something in the uh in the
idea that that Kevin McCarthy is a
representative from that liberal State
of California do you think there might
be something at play here is why um why
people can't stomach him because they
get these delusional ideas right now
let's go to Pete Aguilar let's see what
Pete has to say Hakeem Jeffries of New
York
much more enthusiasm much more
enthusiasm I want to point out they're
excited about their leader
hmm it is almost like Nancy Pelosi made
sure of this
and you know I know a lot of people
don't like to hear this because we fight
Republicans pretty damn hard and there's
a handful of them out there that aren't
complete turds in the Punchbowl
back in the 90s we had people switch
parties
we need to get back to that we need to
be courting some of these Republicans
that are sick of this [ __ ]
[Applause]
United by a speaker who will put people
over politics Hakeem Jeffries has worked
his entire life to improve Economic
Opportunity for all people he is
committed to strengthening The American
Dream by lowering costs for Working
Families building safer communities by
taking weapons of war off streets and by
creating good paying jobs in industries
of the future as we work to implement
our historic legislative accomplishments
weird he didn't say republican once
house Democrats are united behind a
speaker who wants to make things in
America and bring home jobs that have
been shipped overseas to write a tax
code
much more enthusiastic
[Applause]
listen Texas Paul
the majority of politics is performance
and the Democrats are performing here
and making sure that the American people
know that Democrats are way more
enthusiastic about their speaker
nomination than Republicans produces our
country's dependence on fossil fuels
from voting say that again my friend
we are united
Madam Clerk
we are unified behind a speaker
who is an Unapologetic advocate for
protecting and expanding our freedom
he does not traffic in extremism
[Music]
[Applause]
boom he does not grovel to or make
excuses for a twice impeached so-called
former president
boom God damn
[Applause]
Aguilar going for the throat here
Madam clerk he does not bend a knee to
anyone who would seek to undermine our
democracy
[Applause]
I love this guy this is how democracy
Works folks you're watching democracy
live and in person because Madam clerk
that's not what leaders do
because he understands what great
leaders of this house understand that
this body and this institution are best
equipped to serve the needs of this
democracy in the beautiful Mosaic of the
members it sends that our responsibility
as members of this body is to protect
the American dream and honor the
sacrifice of the generations before us
like the sacrifice of a mother and a
social worker who borrowed against her
pension to put her children through
school
mom and dad were determined that their
children would graduate without any debt
so that they could pursue their dreams
to their best of their ability no matter
the hardship or the sacrifice
today hakeem's leadership style is quite
simple
spread love it's the Brooklyn way
[Applause]
he's gonna make a great speaker by the
way Texas ball
one hell of a speaker at King Jeffries
is gonna make yeah he's a scrapper he's
a real Scrapper and he understands how
it works right he understands whooping
votes that's right in that same Borough
Hakeem and his brother were raised in
the first home that their parents ever
bought thanks to their collectively
bargained salary and it's where they
live today
it was in this house where his younger
brother saw a future leader where his
mother saw a thoughtful passionate young
man and where his father saw a
competitor whose GPA went up when his
younger brother started High School
his family always at his side some here
with us today and some watching from
home his mom and dad Kenny JJ Joshua and
his younger brother Dr Hassan Jeffries
Mrs Jeffries and her husband told their
sons it doesn't matter what you do but
it has to be done in the service of
people
and that's how Hakeem will lead
he's going to serve all of us so that we
can best serve the American public
that selflessness that commitment to
success of those around you is what
shaped his career and what will shape
our joint future together
he knows success isn't about Personal
Achievement he's a leader who will be
with you in the beginning whether it's
your bill and an important priority in
your District he'll write alongside you
as you do the work and he'll be there at
the end to see you through
because he knows that our success means
that we can raise the quality of life
for our constituents creating better
jobs and building safer communities he
has guided every step of the way by his
faith his mom his mom instilled in him
Sunday mornings weren't always easy in
the Jeffrey's house the young man who
knew he wanted to be a lawyer would
argue with his mom about going to church
that day
but failure is a good teacher
he lost those arguments
and now Hakeem goes to church every
weekend sometimes that one where his
church family is at Cornerstone Baptist
or somewhere else in the district where
he can meet his constituents where they
are he remembers that after church on
Sundays he'd go to Nano's house where
there was an open door at his
grandmother's house for the entire
neighborhood and their Elders to come
through with food and conversation a
young Hakeem listening to everything
but usually just trying to catch the
score of the Jets game
this is where wisdom gets passed down
and now Guided by the faith and wisdom
of leaders like Jim Clyburn Greg Meeks
John Lewis steny Hoyer Nancy delisandro
Pelosi
Gabe Sanchez is joining us
as the Democrats applauded King Jeffries
and Nancy Pelosi it gave much more
enthusiastic uh Pete Aguilar is whipping
up the Democrats here on the house floor
but let's take a listen prepared to
nominate a leader who will open the door
to the new generation of leadership
Madam clerk a Latino is nominating for
leader of this chamber a black man for
the first time in our history
[Applause]
I don't see many uh Republicans standing
up for that I don't see one of them nope
Madam Madam clerk that's progress and
it's progress that the country wants to
continue for this Congress and for our
country
therefore as chair of the democratic
caucus I am directed by the vote of that
caucus to present for election to the
office of Speaker of the House of
Representatives for the 118th Congress
the name of the honorable Hakeem
Jeffries representative elect from the
state of New York
so there we see a much more enthusiastic
Unified
right
just I mean to have enthusiasm behind
your Your Leader your denomination of
your leader I would say means something
right I guess we lost Texas ball there
maybe
um he'll be back yeah it's uh I mean it
really it really does tell you something
I mean like the Republican party has
been pointing fingers and trying to find
excuses the for the reason why the Red
Wave was a red tinkle they've had no
they've had no legitimate reason that
they've been able to actually put
forward
a representative elect from
have been placed in
the number here we go here's where the
drama May begin and as Jim we don't have
drama already
Paul gozar is going to speak the Traders
going to speak on the house floor here
the power doesn't reside in the speaker
it doesn't in the majority of your North
minority
nor the whip
the power resides and we the people the
people [ __ ] trust is us here each
individual member to represent their
District their state and the federal
government
Washington's broken
we're the last ones to know
wise person once told me good process
you know it's good policy bill's good
policy I want to put a meme in here of
January 6 and say disu is that how
Washington's broken Paul goes right [ __ ]
any Biggs for speaker of the house thank
you
here we go oh they're really
enthusiastic too yay
there being no
Clerk of points the following tellers
the gentleman from Georgia miss a lot of
milk
the gentlewoman from California Miss Lee
the gentleman from Wisconsin Mrs Steele
and the gentleman from New York Mr
Morelli
the tellers will come forward and take
their seats at the desk in front of the
speaker's Rostrum
okay so we're gonna we're gonna watch
the um the vote to start to unfold here
we we you know again Kevin McCarthy was
put up uh by at least stefanik from the
Republican caucus uh the chair she's the
chair of the Republican caucus and um
then uh Paul gozar and true
true nincompoop Nazi fashion gets up
um he's an insurrectionist he play
helped plan the Insurrection we know
this
um from evidence of the January 6th
select committee he nominates Annie
Biggs is Andy Biggs an interaction as to
Gabe Sanchez it's almost like I said in
the first 30 minutes Donald Trump is to
blame for all this chaos it's almost
like Donald Trump I mean a lot of it a
lot of it definitely comes also back to
McCarthy who's unable to even unify this
base McCarthy is a reason why Donald
Trump got a an extra kind of oomph of
energy he's the one who went down to
Mar-A-Lago but I look at this whole
thing and there was something I just
thought of which is I'm surprised George
Santos didn't try to nominate himself
for house Speaker I mean like he's only
got probably a limited of time amount of
limited amount of time left in the house
before he gets like extradited to Brazil
so the guy is
they're gonna start calling the roll
here
um you see the um you see that the
nominees on the board
now they can call out any name they want
yeah or they can uh that's what others
is and they can also vote present which
changes the number that Kevin McCarthy
would need to get the majority
um the last speaker
um no no it was in yes Nancy Pelosi
actually didn't receive 218 because
there were several present votes but
here's the thing Nancy pelusi blowsy
knew those votes she whipped those votes
so she was able to keep that here we go
here's the boat
Adams
Jeffries I mean when you've already got
a group of people that have a split
nominee with the possibility of writing
to others
it doesn't look so good for either
person
and when you've got a democratic base
who already knows everyone they're
voting for McCarthy
Allen I'm gonna turn this way down so we
can talk over it as they vote yeah um so
if the audience isn't hearing the vote
I'll keep them up to date here
um of course it's going to be really
close between McCarthy and Jeffrey's
through this whole thing
but we'll see how many
um What's Really Gonna matter is the
votes in Biggs category in others
category in the present category is what
is going to determine whether Kevin
McCarthy can receive the speakership on
this first ballot I don't I do not think
I do not think that um McCarthy will
receive it on this first ballot but
we'll see we'll see we'll see Texas ball
you sent me a link here
um to something I I don't want to I
don't want to walk away from the house
floor vote here yeah what was the uh
what was the article that you sent me
that was uh just the articles are
relevant it had a good picture of Renee
Elmer she is the woman that McCarthy uh
let's say blew up his last attempt to
become speaker over
he uh you know a little bit of
on the hand back in a little bit some
sex cocaine orgies or something yeah
yeah it was enough to deny him the
speakership put it that way
you know the the the the the corporate
media really dropped the ball on that
one they
he was up for speakership and to lose to
lose to have to bring in Paul Ryan and a
lot of people don't remember that Paul
Ryan was not destined to become speaker
Kevin McCarthy was next in line and it
was the affair rumors over with Renee
Elmer uh who lost in 2016 I believe uh
if I remember correctly
um that sunk his attempt to become
speaker there was enough there there
that Republicans were scared enough that
they brought in Paul Ryan and the
corporate media said [ __ ] all about it I
mean nothing
Jeffries
so we're at McCarthy at 15. Jeffries at
nine now again this is a slow process
because it is a Voice vote
um and there there's no proxy that can
happen on this vote it all has to be did
Biggs just vote for himself
of course of course he stood up it was
like uh-huh yeah I will be the only one
me he looks at he's like look there's at
least two votes in this chamber that
will vote for me myself
and also ghosts right right you know the
the most significant vote that is going
to be caught on camera today is George
Santos
um it is like it is
he he just [ __ ] made you never know
what's gonna come out of that guy's
mouth dude the guy has been that guy has
been running around like a rat all
around the capitol trying to avoid I
don't know if you guys watch the videos
but uh I hope we get to the clips today
I hope we get to some of these clips
today but that we've got to oh
absolutely George
if you didn't catch it Lauren Bower just
voted for Jim Jordan The Honorable The
Honorable
honorable or As Trump would say quote
unquote honorable okay so so right now
right now there is uh three votes not
for Kevin McCarthy in the Republican
Congress the most significant part about
that is uh if there is two more if he
well if he if he loses two more votes
but if there's a present vote he could
still push it over the top so he is on
thin ice right now in this first ballot
already
um but but the the fact that Lauren
bobert voted for Jim Jordan is going to
be just as good a videotape as George
Santos voting three or four times today
for Kevin McCarthy
do you think George Santos pops up for
his name but then pops up randomly just
throwing out other names oh she she
thinks he's gonna vote more than once I
think you're like stand up with someone
else like he'll put like one of the yeah
the sunglasses with the nose and the
mustache on and he'll try to vote in
someone else's place probably he'll
probably put a wig on you know like okay
okay now there's there's four votes
there's four votes
for others
two others and two for Biggs
my my my uh my bit is that Santos votes
for for Lula
that guy does not want to go back to
Brazil man apparently apparently Brazil
is CR is gonna crawl up his ass
um I don't know exactly what the charges
were but apparently there were charges
against him and they were there was the
there was the people who moved the check
there was the check fraud charge right
so I don't know what else there is he
was writing he was writing bad chicks is
that the thing pretty much no it's worse
than that actually of course it is it's
Santa's he's a republican of course it's
worse than it seems on the surface
person
I did see someone post today and I
haven't been able to to fact check this
so if anyone out there knows uh I did
see something about the US and Brazil in
talks so if the doj doesn't take action
then Brazil can now again I don't know
if that's true or not I haven't done any
uh background check on that fact Kenneth
but if that's true then yeah 100 I I
hope to God I cannot wait for the day
that they [ __ ] put bracelets on him
and take him out of the house Chambers
well by seating Santos the Republicans
have really opened a can of worms here
because you know at least I'm gonna talk
about Santos for the next two years I
don't care what happens to him yeah but
I mean
it's a real legal crisis they've created
because uh Brazil had an open
investigation on Santos because he stole
the checkbook of the guy his mother this
is the allegations down in Brazil he
stole the checkbook of a guy that his
mother was working for
then went to a clothing store
and wrote about I think 700 bucks worth
of fraudulent checks for clothes so he
stole 700 bucks worth of clothes plus he
stole a checkbook and then wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
back up back up back up he stole the
checkbook of the person Santos's mother
the one that died in 911 worked for yeah
mother or does he have different mothers
no that's the same mother yeah the one
that died on 9 11 in 2016 yeah yeah yeah
the one who he also he said died of
cancer I don't know if she really did uh
the the the little obituary announcement
uh was was weird if you guys actually
read it
um yeah when you die of Shame right it
refers to her as it it was very odd uh
but the other thing too is like what was
it 2008 was the latest point which he
left Brazil but he had he had spoken so
much about it like oh I was born and
raised in New York and I was a kid and
that lived in the basement here and this
and that and it's just it just like
doesn't add up I'm like I'm gonna end up
doing a what was that on this because
it's just I just needed too every day
there's something new and I wanted him
to I wanted him to actually be sworn in
before I made the what was that Jeffries
when I look at the situation and as far
as as far as George Santos is concerned
because there was a little bit of drama
on Twitter with some kind of I know he
claims to be a billionaire some lawyer
down in Miami I guess The Daily Beast
wrote a story about this guy is that
what it is tell me what that what the
hell was that drama whoa what's going on
here oh there Jeffries takes the lead
well he is he's 35 to 32 is the
Jeffrey's lead right now
um of course this is going to be close
the entire time
um as they as they take through these
votes when was the last time so out of
curiosity when was the last time if we
know
1913. no 1923. it was the last time when
the House Majority didn't have a
representative there well well um it
went past the first but there we go he
lost he just lost yeah five votes that
were not for McCarthy so that means who
was that I didn't catch it
we're not paying attention here too much
to the uh actually oh
yeah see if you can um um see the live
update somewhere it might be on um the
house.gov
the actual live count
um but we we have we have three for Bigs
three for others they're really gonna
pile onto bigs and others now is what
they're going to do
so we so we've got 38 for Jeffrey's 33
for McCarthy three for Biggs and three
for others
um one specifically for Jim Jordan from
uh Bobo the Clown which and that's the
reason why she is a clown is because
she's voting for Jim Jeffries Jim Jim
Jordan excuse me Jesus Christ I'm
getting um names configured Jim Jordan
as
and can you put can you put the the
captions on on your video that way we
might be able to catch anyone released
let me see
there we go yeah there we go Courtney
I'm still looking to see who these other
people were Craig
Jeffrey's starting to stack up the vote
because the Democrats are in the um
are in the alphabetical count there so
they go alphabetically
um through these members that's why it
you know they're not going like one
Republican one Democrat they're going
alphabetically through it wow we've got
this is this is there's no finagling
here yeah he's done well the only way
the only way
the only way that yeah uh we just seen
uh Dan Crenshaw the the one-eyed pirate
from Texas
um
so so the only way that Texas Paul that
he would be able to actually get this
vote on the first ballot is if there are
several members of the Republican caucus
that vote present
um and he gets the votes because he has
to have the majority of votes but that
won't work
with the number of votes that are
stacking up against him because that
will actually make Jeffries the Speaker
of the House listen listen there's
nothing wrong with that don't do not put
it past that there may be Republicans
sneakily uh making sure that they have
an actual leader here because that is
going to be the difference between
Republican McCarthy being speaker and
Jeffrey's Democrat being speaker because
Republicans are going to have to pay for
the shutdown in September if McCarthy
ends up being speaker after four ballots
five ballots 20 ballots whatever it
takes that the government is going to
shut down in September if Jeffries is
the speaker of the house it will not
shut down in September we will not have
a government shutdown
McCartney you know it's just the only
way
McCarthy's just going to be humiliated
here because the only way for this to go
to another vote now is for every
Republican they can't vote present they
can't because if they if enough of them
vote present they make Jeffries the
speaker so they actually have to go
through this entire motion and just
humiliate McCarthy so because Jeffries
will not have how many people Jeffries
doesn't have the votes how many votes
you think is stacked against them 10 12.
I have no idea I expected five to be
honest with words yeah
I mean how many how many people are
within the America first group that's
what you got to remember right so you've
got Lauren bobert Margie Taylor green
Matt Gates Scott Perry Scott Perry
you've already got obviously Andy Biggs
voting for himself those are those are
voting for any Biggs
this is one of those things where Lauren
bobert voting for Jim Jordan which is
right that was what an idiot
and reminding folks that that even
though Jeffrey's is going to win this
vote handily now he is uh he cannot
become speaker without a full majority
of the vote so as long as the
Republicans don't start voting present
Jeffries will not become speaker on this
vote
um the the most important thing though
is you said he's gonna Kevin McCarthy's
gonna be humiliated
um I just looked it up Texas Paul
humiliated is actually his legal middle
name
um so I just I just want to point that
out to the audience that it's it's Kevin
H McCarthy uh H is for humiliated
um at least that's what he should change
his name too now that's you
Jeffries
so we're waiting for the uh big reveal
here of um Kevin McCarthy being The
Biggest Loser on the house floor today
um
and man I want to go get some popcorn
well apparently yeah became ready that's
crazy
I'm sure somewhere in the um in the um
the wing rooms that there's popcorn
machines oh yeah all of the eggs have
the microwaves just running oh yeah
[Laughter]
Ferguson this is hilarious I do 2023
who's going to start great but this is
hilarious I mean I don't know if you
guys watched uh if you guys are watching
the Tesla stock but that's a new year
new low oh yeah so so now not only is
the Republicans tanking in the house but
Tesla's tanking on the market what a
what a what a fantastic first start to
um to the Republicans Taking Over part
of our it's at 105 20. holy [ __ ] well I
I wondered the other the other day how
long it would take to get below 100.
it's already it's almost it's almost
down 18 bucks how long do you think it's
gonna get do you think it's gonna get
down to 60 70.
I think it could I think it'll get
double digits uh I don't know about well
I'm sure it'll get that low I think
in three days it'll definitely be double
digits in the 90s okay so we're tying
McCarthy 62 Jeffrey 62. uh obviously
cart McCarthy
um is gonna have uh can't come back here
because of the Biggs votes and the
others votes did you find out what those
um those votes were no I can't see those
votes live so I have to resort to uh see
if you can see if someone on Twitter is
uh that's reliable either Hugo maybe
Scott McFarland
um Franklin
Kyle Chaney might well he's doing doj
might not be covering this um today but
why you mentioned Kyle Chaney big shout
out to Kyle Chaney over at Politico
um I actually did a couple pieces for
Midas just to just that's what I was
doing before I came in was was
transferring them to the editor Kyle
Chaney with the releases from the
January 6 committee has been doing an
amazing job
I am a commentator I am not a
journalists
um real quick
um Matt gatz just voted for Andy Biggs
that puts Biggs at five and others at
three go ahead sorry about that yeah no
no worries I mean this is hilarious but
no Kyle Chaney has been really busting
his ass he's been top-notch on the
releases from the January you know we
did such in-depth coverage of the
January 6 hearings but
real hard-working journalists have have
provided us commentators with so much
material and and and Kyle Chaney's been
top-notch I cannot scream out enough
what a great job that guy's doing
there's a lot there's a lot of really
good journalists out there Kyle's one of
them uh I I we lean heavy on this show
with the Scott McFarlane
um I've got those I've got those votes
if you want to know yeah yeah who's all
right so we've got Andy Biggs voted for
himself right uh Dan Bishop voted for
Andy Biggs Lauren bobert voted for Jim
Jordan
uh uh Josh brecking voted for Jim Banks
um let's see
Michael Cloud voted for Jim Jordan
Andrew Clyde the guy who if everyone
doesn't know Andrew Clyde's the guy who
said January 6 was just another tourist
visit type of day he voted for Andy
Biggs surprise surprise oh yeah uh
Elaine crane voted for Andy Biggs so at
that point they've already got seven
defections right
um
yes
so there's two votes for um Jim Jordan
one for Jim Banks
uh
scalicians yeah and Elise stephanic are
are uh are logging the votes by hand so
it sounds like they're Counting
uh to see where everyone uh Falls in
what a humiliation to not have whipped
this enough to know where this vote is
going yeah but Texas Paul they tried to
whip it for three weeks and that's the
point is why Kevin McCarthy is not going
to be a successful speaker don't you
think
yeah he's just well he's weak he's not
he's he's not well liked he's he he's
got foot and mouth disease he's got uh
he's just gonna be a [ __ ] show for the
Republicans which is you know great for
us Democrats politically but shitty for
the country
we're we're uh we're at 10 votes
uh against McCarthy seven for Biggs and
then three for the others still uh I do
want to so somebody I just the chat's
going by really quick I just uh had to
verify this but it turns out George
Santos arrived to the house for a
swearing-in ceremony without his wedding
band or his husband
uh well it it and we confirmed that he's
actually married is there a marriage
license that someone has confirmed
I have not even looked that up I can
look up marriage license in the state I
mean I mean I'm just saying that that
it's possible he's not actually married
that's why he wouldn't show up with his
ring and and a husband if he's not
actually we already we learned recently
about the uh the the young the young boy
uh that he was in talks with
uh let me just confirm that though okay
guest
McCarthy
Guthrie you know George Santos's ex-wife
uh she as in female was really surprised
to hear he was gay
and I air quotes gay I mean because who
is it surprised when Santa says
something though Texas Paula
oh my gosh this is crazy yeah at age 26
he was involved with an 18 year old this
is something that's came out on the uh
on January 1st
yeah
um everyone's pointing this out that
this is called here
um there he can't and Kevin McCarthy
cannot overcome this vote he is not
going to win on the first ballot this is
the first time in a hundred years a few
years that uh someone has not won on the
first ballot and the reason why can't
win dude there's no way there's even if
McCarthy somehow pulls out a win on the
next vote
there's no way that he has any control
of his party no I mean not that he had
one to begin with well I mean that's
that's what Texas Paul was saying is you
can't you can't expect someone to be a
speaker if he can't whip votes like
that's the whole [ __ ] that's the whole
job yeah hell
or McCarthy
Hines
so we're going to watch as um Kevin
McCarthy and boy it it really does look
bleak
horseford
again you're watching um something that
hasn't happened in the house on the
house floor in over a hundred years
where a the person who was nominated as
Speaker did not receive
on the first ballot enough votes to
become speaker
I know it would be really fascinating to
me is if Jeffries would take enough if
there's enough people that vote for
Biggs or other that Jeffers can actually
have people at the tail end of the road
called vote present and still have
enough votes to be the majority I wonder
what the mathematical calculation is on
that I don't have a math brain enough to
figure that out but that would be an
amazing maneuver right well I mean
um right now McCarthy S90 and Jeffrey
has 87. we're at 11 votes against
McCarthy in the Republican caucus
alphabetical so we don't know like you
know there could be more letters on that
side in the Republican party and that's
why we're getting those tally UPS well
you know we we don't we're not wearing
khakis and have a special board like
Steve karnacki on MSNBC so quarterly
manaki where's corduroy well I just
think Steve karnacki would wear khaki
right because it
maybe it's not corduroy but quarter
round quarter round feels like
aerodynamic you're moving like back and
forth oh really so it's it goes in
between the seams instead of against
each other you know all right well I'm
not promoting Steve carnacky and his
khaki artist corduroy whichever it is
here we go um 91 for Jeffries who was
the who was the other vote that just
happened I missed it damn it uh here
I'll look it up
too distracted about mocking these
[ __ ] Jim Jordan voted for himself no
I'm joking I'm joking that may be that
may be is Jim Jordan wearing a jacket
he's on the floor he's supposed to
Jim Jeffries just voted for himself and
the Democrats are cheering
what if he paused and he was like
Jeffries
uh here let's see
another two okay Matt Gates Bob good
voted for Paul gosar uh Bob good for
Paul gozar no no sorry sorry uh Bob good
and Paul gosar voted for Andy Banks oh
okay I see it uh Andy Harris votes for a
non-house member former rep Lee zeldin
oh well
I don't I don't know I don't know if you
guys know this but Lee zeldon is the one
who he's a loser as well he's a loser in
New York in the governor's race
technically legal you can do it it is
allowed
double digit votes against McCarthy you
know what's significant here is there
hasn't been a vote for Donald Trump yet
I know that seems not significant but
there's four other votes here and one of
them is a non-house member
and it's not Donald Trump
yeah and you know the screwed up part
about this is I don't see the
Republicans getting more in line with
this next vote I just see it getting
more chaotic I don't know I may be wrong
about that but that's the feeling I'm
getting they take the vote immediately
after are they going to take a quick
recess well no uh they can they can stay
on the floor and keep voting now um in
1923 I believe they voted four times
they adjourned and they did I think it
was um about four or five days before
they can actually put together a vote
for a speaker now you have to remember
that the Republican caucus cannot move
forward with business until they have a
speaker there is not going to get [ __ ]
none in our government and in the
legislative branch the House of
Representatives specifically I mean
they're gonna as long as you don't have
a speaker and they're going to try and
be like it's the Democrats it's like
well the Democrats voted for one person
and one person only you guys split your
boats between between four or five
people by the end of it and this morning
McCarthy did say that he was going to
keep the house in session until as long
as it took well I mean I mean I don't
know if I don't know if anyone watched
the videos last night but he had all of
his uh his
materials put into the house Speaker
office
well yeah funny about that is the fact
that he had them load everything up and
set up the office as if he had the
position
what's gonna be even funnier and when he
doesn't get it they have to now take all
of that [ __ ] that he set up put it back
in the boxes roll it out onto carts and
then bring whoever is going to win that
position you know fingers crossed it is
Jeffries but the idea that you just
assume you've got the position is such a
republican move by the way oh yeah
absolutely well I mean it's a Santos way
baby I mean just just to assume things
to assume that no one's listening to
assume that No One's Gonna check you I
mean this they are the fraud party they
are the fraud party
Lamborghini and you know the the the
thing that just is so freaking telling
is that you could sit here and you could
say this vote could go on for weeks
oh yeah
not you know
um historically anybody else we would be
saying no freaking way they're going to
get this done you know today they're
going to get this done today but the
Republicans are in such disarray and so
weak to even say oh this could go on for
weeks there is actually
a significant chance that this could
actually drag on oh yeah I mean that is
just so freaking amazing to me well I
think I think the um in in the 1860s
Texas Paul the longest that we went
without a speaker because of this
situation that we have right now I
believe it was in the 1860s was almost
nine months
um Our House of Representatives didn't
go or went without a speaker sometime in
the 1860s I believe or maybe was the
1850s
right at or during the um Civil War but
wouldn't that be better do you have it
well I mean I believe that it would be
better to not have a speaker than a
republican speaker yes if that's what
you're asking yeah I mean because
there's not gonna they're not going to
do any house business anyways I mean
no they're just gonna try to have [ __ ]
committees
so according to what I've seen so far it
says the house needed two months and 133
votes to elect a speaker and that was in
uh for the first time in exactly 100
years
so that that was that was that was 1923
right
yeah this this was
but the longest speaker vote began on
December 3rd 1855 when your 34th
Congress convened Democrats controlled
the Senate but no party controlled the
house after the disintegration with the
Whig party after a third house members
were Democrats the rest belonged to a
mix of parties including a new
Republican party many were members of
these uh secretive American party also
known as the know-nothing party
um so I'm reading there that that was
two months and yeah always two months I
thought it was yeah
sorry my my memory is off but it was in
the 1850s it was 1885. um and and you're
seeing then it was more official then
because they had actual parties they had
secret parties but it's the same now
there is no one Republican party Texas
Paul there's no one unified Republican
party is what you're talking about
there's these different factions there's
the America First Nazi party there's
there's the the quote-unquote oh
conservatives that are still trying to
hold on to the mantle of the old
Republican party and then and then
there's these people in the middle being
pulled by politics and they're and their
want for power and being pulled by these
members on either side to try to make
sure that they can keep their control I
think that's what you're saying Texas
Paul
yeah I mean if if the Republican Party
were to return to any semblance of a
governing party
Biggs Gates gosar uh Lauren bobert
Mars large Mars the elevator flagellator
um
they're they're all out of business
because what did what does Lauren bobert
contribute to a legislative process
nothing nothing at all she's got no job
she's not a policy maker she's a goddamn
social media influencer exactly
there's not as much enthusiasm
as there was Jeffries for Jeffrey's did
you notice that yeah yeah there's so
much more enthusiasm about Democrats and
their leaders it's almost like when the
media says Democrats are in disarray
they're full of [ __ ] [ __ ] when the
media tells you like Young Turks and
David packman tell you that it's this
this [ __ ] defeatism that Democrats
are done and they can't win but it's not
true that the the Democratic the
pro-democracy Coalition in this country
is strong it is stronger than ever and
the reason why is because the
Republicans are weak
yeah I think it's because we learned our
lesson to be honest with you you know
you know I I started the ride or die
movement a couple years ago when I first
came on social media because I was sick
of that [ __ ] I was sick of the
infighting you know the Bernie Bros
versus The Establishment and all this
other stuff you know we need we we have
become the party that we will fight it
out we will fight it out
you know coming up into the elections we
will go into the primaries and you will
have your beliefs I will have mine and
we'll fight our asses off but now now
finally when it's election time we go
into that no protest votes no [ __ ]
we go in and we vote Democrat because we
know that's the best way forward and
this [ __ ] you're absolutely right I am
so sick and damn tired of the corporate
media and their [ __ ] narratives that
they keep trying to push on people it is
it's ridiculous we have never been a
better organized more motivated party
ever
and to hear it in the social media you
know we can't even find our damn car
keys you know I mean it's it's
it's [ __ ]
well I I mean the the corporate media
and these other Talking Heads these old
ass pundits that don't know what the
hell they're talking about
um bought into all the Republican
Narrative of the polls and all this [ __ ]
they always have to give they have to
give oxygen to the right because they
feel like they have to be fair and
balanced and there's no fair and balance
in our democracy right now there's only
one party
there's only one party in government
that is actually serious about our
democracy and continuing it and that's
Democrats and Until you realize that you
realize that the Republican party is out
on its last limb here and this is a
prime example of that you're seeing it
right play out now there's another um
there's another vote for other so we're
up to 13 votes against McCarthy I said I
said in the beginning what do you think
next ball 10 or 12 and we're already to
13. we're past what I was trying to
think is a high number here yeah I tell
you I said five
I'm trying to I'm I'm keeping count in a
spreadsheet as we go so like right now
we've got a remainder of
151 votes to go
Gabe you are amazing man
he's over there making calculations he's
trying to do the uh I got no khakis on
over here yeah well I'm keeping a I'm
keeping a running board but we're
keeping the audience you are much cooler
than cornacky man we you are much cooler
than kornacky and I like Steve kornacki
so that's a hell of a compliment thank
you
so again we're up to 13 votes against
Liberty here which is the most important
thing that that we can stress here is
that there's seven for Bigs and six for
others
you see karushi in the comments Gabe
kornacki
Gabe garnacky oh [ __ ] is Gabe wearing
soft pants I I'm wearing soft pants
right now I figured I might as well if I
was gonna sit in for this I might as
well be comfy you know I I was gonna go
just in my undies today but I did put
shorts on well I know I know I have
further for the audience members
watching thank you for the people
listening you can't see you can't see
and I'm not gonna pull a tube in here
oh my God
just to give the audience update there's
145 for McCarthy 137 for Jeffrey 7 for
Biggs and six for other no present votes
currency
we are sub what was what was oh my God
Texas well what happened there you
talking about tubing I tell you what
what are you what are you getting images
in your mind
fantastic
explosion of a career man I mean just
just talk about blowing yourself out of
out of the world blowing your load all
over the um the screen to destroy your
career is that what you're saying I'm
just saying
oh we got another vote for Biggs yeah so
we're eight for big six for others so
we're at 14 now against McCartney that's
the most important part and that listen
well we're forming a national narrative
around this today and as we move forward
you're we because because
um now there may be less votes against
McCarthy in the next ballot but it is
important that you say whatever the
number is 14 15 20 whatever it ends up
being here we are we're now we're at 15.
we're at 15 votes now against McCarthy
that is how you need to frame it out
there with the narratives 15 Republicans
voted against their leader 15 of them
not five not four that they thought 15
this point you know though I mean if if
as we get farther down into the alphabet
you'll start seeing Democrat votes for
Jeffrey's piling up yeah if we get
enough I mean we're at 15 for Biggs and
others it actually is a plausible
maneuver to think about now
but Jeffrey's throwing a few into
presents Texas ball can you imagine can
you imagine there's no red wave and we
come out of this first ballot and Hakeem
Jeffries the Democrat is the goddamn
Speaker of the House
can you imagine Trump there would be
ketchup all over the walls and it's his
doing this is this is Trump's doing here
this vote for Biggs and this vote for
other is well here's that the the former
Speaker of the House Nancy Pelosi voting
for Akeem Jeffries uh with true class
and style there this is what it looks
like to pass the Baton from leader to
leader not like it is on the other side
of the aisle
um Kevin mccarth is I earned it give it
to me
but but this is Donald Trump's doing in
making the Republicans cause chaos and
this is what I keep telling the audience
about Donald Trump running in a
Republican primary for the president
United States he is in a Republican
primary he is running against
Republicans and what you're seeing now
is what we'll see in that race and it is
super important that we politicize every
moment of Perry just voted for Biggs
Scott Perry the the one that is likely
under criminal investigation for
um the the actual State elector scheme
and the January 6th Insurrection Scott
Perry just voted for Biggs which is not
surprising another Insurrection so we're
up to 16. we've got 16 uh again
McCarthy's
152 159 we're down to 117 remaining okay
so so we're at 152 for McCarthy 151 for
Jeffrey's now 116 remaining
we're tied McCarthy and Jeffries are
tied
Porter Jeffries has now taken the lead I
feel like we're I Jefferson now
um Jeffries is now still in Lena 154
153.
Jeffries
quickly whose phone is going off I can
hear it in here
it's not mine no I know I'm saying
someone's oh
that's that's crazy because their
microphones suck c-span's microphones
are their room microphones are horrible
Jeffrey
some Democrats making points
um as they as they vote 157 here we go
58 how many how many votes do we have
left
109. no wait hold on 107. okay
yeah so we still got a broad margin yeah
yeah
but we don't know we we don't know as of
right now because of the alphabetical
list we don't know how many Democrats
how many Republicans are left about it
looks like what are we in ours right now
yeah Rogers Rose
uh the one I wanna I wanna watch is
Marjorie Taylor green and Santos we
still have those on the alphabetical
list of votes oh yeah
uh here's another vote for Biggs
Rosendale voted for big wow
17 votes against Kevin McCarthy Kevin
McCarthy cannot hold this caucus
together at all he will be the worst
speaker if he becomes speaker
if and that's a big one at this point
uh Texas Paul getting 17 votes against
him on the first ballot I would imagine
this is going to go into next week
honestly
um if he was if he was able to fend off
and have five or six votes against him
he could probably win it sometime today
but this is going to take much more
negotiation than than negotiating on the
house floor and rebooting somebody's 18
votes Donald's Donald's just got a vote
Donald's Donald is that a House member
so we're at 18 votes against Kevin
McCarthy
um yeah it's Donald see who is Donald
Donald
uh and it's tied now between McCarthy
and Jeffries Byron Donald's I believe is
who they're referring to
Jeffrey uh so Jeffries is taking a lead
again again I feel like we're we're um
calling a horse race here
this is this is fun this is a lot funner
than I thought it was going to be yeah
sub we are 90. you're muted Texas Ball
by the way
how many seats do we have left unfilled
at this point
[Music]
96. now you have to remember there's one
there's gonna be one less vote because
there's gonna be one less vote
that um because we had a Democrat die
between the election and seating so oh
right so now okay so so we have actually
one last vote
again it's neck and neck between
McCarthy and Jeffrey's here
um for the vote again keeping keeping
that one vote in mind uh let's see 161
163 10 8
a car thing oh there we go quickly did
you see him
he barely got it out and he's sitting
back down
he didn't want that moment on camera
apparently
oh he's like I don't need that I've I'm
already having a hard enough trouble
trying to find my way in the building so
so so Santos did vote for Kevin McCarthy
yeah which was expected right we all
assumed well I mean he is a fraud so why
wouldn't he vote for another fraud I
mean it makes sense
Snyder
Jeffries now has a five vote lead
ERS
yes folks we're in the asses
[Applause]
so keeping in mind we've got 434 votes
and we're at the bottom of the second
hour of the show
um I'm gonna I'm gonna go past this
first vote if it goes past the top of
the hour guys
um I I don't know Texas ball if you can
hang with us if you can oh absolutely
okay so we're if this vote goes past the
top of the hour we're going to stay with
it and then I'm gonna show a couple
videos and clips that I want um folks to
see uh namely the ones of Santos running
away in the hallway and then I also want
to show clips of Evan McCarthy running
away in all the way and then possibly
clips from this morning of the
infighting that happened after Kevin
McCarthy told them to go get [ __ ]
um about their about their demands
that's why there's 19 votes against
McCarthy
because McCarthy did not he's not giving
any concessions for their demands
uh Jefferson
just just happened um but there's 175
for Jeffrey's 166 for McCarthy we're
looking right now at
all right 176
right now we're looking at 73 votes
remaining
and we're pounding Durham here we're
going it's going fast because that the
writing is on the wall now
um that Kevin McCarthy is not going to
be speaker after this first ballot I
mean even the fact that he lost this
first one is embarrassing enough you
know whatever the outcome of the next
votes are like the fact you can't get
the first one and you and you supposedly
control the house
we're at the Smiths now
we're we're at the Smiths uh we're past
the Smiths there's about 10 of them I
think
Sorenson Jeffries
soda I will tell you folks there are
enough votes sitting out there right now
against McCarthy that Jeffries could
could conceivably
throw the last you know it looks like
he's going to have at least a
what uh I mean 14 point 13 point lead 13
vote lead we know we know he'll at least
have 213. we know that for sure yeah
and and but it'll the difference the
what the import to get to the majority
the 218
he should have enough you know enough
votes to actually start throwing some
into present
and he actually could conceivably become
speaker on this vote I guess so I think
the Republicans have screwed up here hey
um um Gabe can you can you pull the
picture of Ted Lou yeah and make it as a
tile and load it in
um so I can show that to folks Ted Lou
actually um
while we're watching here I can show
um
him eating popcorn because that may be a
very critical moment in American history
here
um as Texas Paul is stressing
um Democrats could outmaneuver the
Republicans here depending on the
alphabetical order and how many votes
that are left
um and you know there's someone doing
math somewhere
um not just Steve kornacki and Gabe
Sanchez someone's doing math somewhere
um to know if there is a way a path for
Jeffries to actually walk away from this
um
as the Speaker of the House well I I
don't think that that's a likelihood
but you know Republicans lose badly and
they lose with great Flair and styles
yeah when they lose they lose babies yes
it's it's a fantastic win it was
fantastic it was the best it was the
best loss ever
you know speaking of that we got 19
votes against
um uh against McCarthy there's uh 189
for Jeffrey's 184 McCarthy now 190 for
Jeffries so he's got a 10 point lead
let's check and see I'm gonna check on
my phone while we're waiting of what how
Grandpa poopy pants if he's um oh he's
he's posting about Ruby Freeman McCarthy
oh yeah yeah yeah he's showing it he's
going in on Ruby Freeman yeah he's doing
the whole Q Anon thing huh yeah yeah
okay well
um it looks like his last post was um
just an hour ago
I admire you guys for being able to look
at truth social I can't do it I can't do
it I only look at his account that's it
they just look at his account that's the
only reason why I have it Jeffries I
mean maybe I should build a Following
over there I don't know maybe you know
it's funny I tried posting stuff and I
get flagged and it says this is
sensitive material well I mean I think I
think the very I only have one post over
there and I posted I think I posted a
video of him or something or a picture
of him and they [ __ ] flagged it I
didn't like it
uh so Jeffries now has a 14 point lead
as Kevin McCarthy's got 19 votes against
him in his caucus
yes so the Jeffrey's lead is almost
Texas ball the the Jeffrey Fleet is
almost as big as the deficit um the
margin that Kevin McCarthy has put
together of people in his caucus loading
against him
you know I'm looking at it
he would need
11 votes to have gone if my math is
correct to have gone to Biggs or other
to be able to do that maneuver because I
mean they're at 213 add five gets you to
218 219 would be six votes he would need
11 votes
um to play with where he could send send
six into present and become speaker
he really could so what because what
you're saying Texas ball is there needs
to be six Democrats that vote present
correct that that would that would make
the because what you have to do is you
have to lower the number of house votes
right exactly by Hakeem Jeffries
lowering the number of of house votes
that makes the majority not 218 anymore
it brings it a lower number so if he
wrote that number and then have present
votes to bring the the house
um vote down but but what could happen
Texas well if Republicans catch on to
this Republicans could also start um
voting well no that would that would put
it in that that would team Jeffries
could be the Speaker of the House in the
first salad oh no [ __ ] way is that
are we are we sure on this it is yeah
because a present vote lowers the number
of votes in the house it doesn't count
as a vote it lowers the total limit how
many votes do we have left Gabe Sanchez
all right because even even with the one
Democrat vote um being deceased it's the
majority is still 17 right now that's
why I said he needs 11 because we have
it won't be 213 it'll be starting at 2
12.
212 uh you know he needs six to get to
218 218 is the majority so if he brings
that bar down with present votes
if you get six people to vote present
that means those votes that he's not
getting
he would need what well he has to reach
a threshold before he starts doing it
we're at 12 votes no we're yeah we've
wrote 12 votes right now that remain uh
and and you notice that the uh the votes
against McCarthy has stopped at 19.
um and hasn't moved in a bit and it may
be because I think Texas ball is onto
something I think Democrats at way out
maneuvered Republicans they were so
concentrated on who was going to vote
what that they missed they missed the
possibility here yeah because by my math
it's 17 votes for Biggs or others leaves
them vulnerable to this [ __ ] we are we
are down to nine votes Wilson of Florida
um if you're watching on our Channel
please please subscribe to the Tony
Michaels podcast while you're here we
have the a ton of people tuning in don't
miss a single uh episode we're live
every Monday through Friday noon Eastern
11 Central 9 Pacific on YouTube Twitter
and twitch
um I know it's hard to hear we got the
volume down
um on the vote but uh we're trying to
keep you abreast of what is happening in
Texas Paul is um we're getting in the
final five using his math brain here to
uh figure out if team Jeffries can
actually pull a hat trick and pull this
out
they didn't do it though
they didn't do it because we're 211
there aren't there aren't the votes out
there to vote president so that it's the
final three votes
yeah 211 is the Democratic caucus this
math doesn't make sense 211 is the
Democratic caucus because there's 212
minus the deceased vote right right but
I've got one Romanian vote on here two
two someone may not have voted you do
not have to vote
because I've already I've already
accounted for 434. so Kevin McCarthy uh
humiliated embarrassed here
um has he doesn't win the first ballot
there's 19 votes against him
um and he doesn't look like he's going
to whip more votes Texas Paul and it
doesn't appear that he's gonna go try to
whip more votes uh Akeem Jeffries
getting more votes on the house floor
for speaker of the house than Kevin
McCarthy I'm counting 432 votes that's
what I've got
there's 202 for McCarthy 2 11 for
Jeffrey's uh 10. uh Biggs and nine
others so I've got 432 on my count which
means that we even with the 434 count
there's two remaining so two people
didn't vote well one one person didn't
vote because there's a no no that's
already oh yeah yeah yeah you're right
you're right so we didn't so two people
did not vote right in the meantime uh
I've got that image of Ted uh yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah you get that uh loaded up
yeah uh where is um
let's see where where do you get it guys
I'm gonna step out for one second while
you pull that up I'll be right back yeah
here's Ted Lou with the popcorn ready to
go ready this morning had a bag of
popcorn red tea to go
well that's um that's that's what he
handed that's what he had to do
Gabe Sanchez this is just
um what what a day on the house floor I
want to um Let me let me uh turn the
sound off on this I'm gonna go to while
we're um waiting on that to happen yeah
let's uh let's see
how do I want to do this ow let's see if
I can find out who those remaining two
people were yeah yeah you mean the no
votes because apparently we have two no
votes
um because you don't have to vote they
don't have to vote on the floor
um
um as that goes on here's here's the
video of Santos or one of the videos I
should say of George Santos the absolute
fraud he's a good Republican though by
the way good solid Republican well yeah
absolutely that's that's this kind of
fraud makes you a good Republican um so
I'm gonna play this here of Santos it
appears Gabe Sanchez that he doesn't
want to um he doesn't want to answer
questions about his lies in his fraud
like most Republicans they just
this is what I'll say I'll say that
George Santos is skid dish
this morning
skidish
you know skid dish
not as easy as skittish skid-ish uh
Texas bald here's here's the eclip Texas
ball from George Santos running away
from the media let's play this
what do you have to say the voters in
your District
[Music]
you were fraudulent sir do you plan to
resign any comment at all whatsoever I
mean
are you going to resign are you going to
resign
I have to say this seems unsustainable
to some degree right like how the [ __ ]
is he gonna guide us up every single day
they show up with it when he he's got
his little lunch pail in his backpack
and he's like I'm going to the Capitol
and every reporter is asking him from
the entrance Point once they walk
through the metal detectors to his
office and he gets lost along the way I
want them to continue to ask about his
past relationships his situation in
Brazil I want to ask about uh uh the
line about him having a brain tumor it's
not a tumor he said he had a brain tumor
his mother died multiple times I want to
know in what Multiverse George Santos
exists and I want to get the answers
as as easily as I can and the easiest
way I know how is people just constantly
just hitting them with questions all
again and again and again yeah I tell
you they've I Gabe Tony they have
created a hell of a mess here like I was
saying earlier because Brazil really
wants to extradite him for this I mean
they still have an open case on him they
archive that case when they when he
split they couldn't find him they
archived the case they are literally
contacting the doj as of a couple days
ago saying hey that's our guy we want to
try him yeah that opens up a huge can of
worms if you think about it because you
know think about what Trump was trying
to do in Ukraine blackmail them to do
anything to help him out politically
Republicans will do that [ __ ] you know
they will just get one of their buddy
buddy Russia to Trump up some damn
charges on somebody in one of their
little satellite freaking countries you
know and and next thing you know we got
somebody being extradited to Slovenia
you know this is a real can of worms
they've opened up because Biden has to
oppose this
he has to oppose the extradition if you
think about it as much as I'm sure he
would love to send George Santos to
Brazil
he has to tell his attorney general we
can't open this can of worms
um I want to go to a Quick Clip here of
the house floor when the first vote was
open because we are going to have a
second vote it's probably not going to
happen in our show today but you can go
to C-SPAN
um and um and and just go to C-SPAN and
just Google it you'll be able to go to
and watch the house floor if you want to
watch the house floor live that's where
I was watching it with C-SPAN
um but here is a clip from the house
floor this is Jim Jordan after the first
vote he goes to Kevin McCarthy and they
start deliberating
um it looks like it looks like Jim
Jordan is going to try to whip for Kevin
McCarthy watch
thank you
here you see uh Jim Jordan
he makes a move down to Kevin McCarthy
now I'm no rip lip reader
um but what it looks like they're doing
is deliberating on whipping boats this
is what happens on the house floor
that's why I was saying after Kevin
McCarthy lost I'm surprised he wasn't um
back slapping some people
to whip boats um that's politics there's
a lot of backslapping back to George
Santo's story
um Gabe Sanchez there was a Daily Beast
article because I know this Brazil thing
is a big deal but what the [ __ ] is this
uh this goddamn attorney
what is this attorney down in Miami what
the hell is it it has to do with the
finances because that's how the feds are
going to get this [ __ ] is
following money so that's the one and
there's way there's so much this I'm not
even all the way into
but there is an attorney in uh
uh in Florida right who I guess gave
massive campaign loans that supposedly
are not so legal as we've learned
everything about George Santos did he
put it in like family names or some [ __ ]
or so there's the there so basically
it's the it's already admitted using
cash for his company in the volder
organization because his devoter
organization is George Sanchos George
Anthony Santos or George Anthony
devolder Santos is the full name I
forgot which which combination you want
to use on which day of the week it is
but basically there was a move of con
there was a move of money that went uh
in the in the amount of seven hundred
thousand dollars which
um Finance experts are saying has added
up to an unlawful uh corporate
contribution
so The Daily Beast had an article that
you can easily just go look up if you
just type in George Santos you'll find
everything on them but basically
look I just want to say this like if you
thought uh Herschel Walker was like the
best or the the number one liar in
America holy [ __ ] George Santos has put
him to shame and The Daily Beast again
has covered this top leading story of
this of this Republican candidate uh and
now Republican uh I'm glad you brought
Herschel Walker into I mean there's no
way
you think the Republicans actually
deputize fakely fraudulently Joshua
Walker with this fake badge to go fake
arrest George Santos do you think that's
I mean who knows they might try to use
it as a win to be like look our own guys
this would only make sense to have a
fake arrest of a fake Congressman with a
fake badge and a fake person who ran
fakely for the United States
what's the what's the like the the most
popular drink in Brazil
um
Santa Orange
okay well in this carrot in this
situation George Santo said hold my fan
to Orange
because that honestly is what came out
of this I mean Herschel Walker told all
these lies documented on video in in
interviews everything
Santos came in and was like aha let me
just one-up You by a lot yeah but this
attorney because I know the Brazil thing
seems cool because it's International
but let me tell you something about the
Department of Justice and Texas poll
will probably back me up on this if the
Department of Justice gets involved in
criminal investigation there's no
[ __ ] way they're going to extradite
this [ __ ] to Brazil those Brazil
if he gets federal charges he is not
going to Brazil Brazil is just has an
open investigation into him and they
know that he's in the United States that
is it because if the doj um has a grand
jury indict him on federal charges
especially if it has anything to do with
these campaign funds and this money with
this lawyer down in um in in Miami this
[ __ ] he claims to be some kind
of billionaire he claims to be rich why
my game Sanchez are all the dumbest
people have so much money why because
this guy was tweeting about this stuff
just incriminating himself even more and
yeah so yeah to sue people and all kinds
of stuff and [ __ ] so it's not the first
time either so this guy uh I've got to
look up his full name but uh Ruiz Ruiz
uh the yeah yeah so
uh it's an influential family in Florida
uh when I like that influential yeah
influential is how the daily is how The
Daily Beast throws it out there but I
guess you know working with there's
there's there are documents that you can
see online You know despite the fact
that this guy Ruiz is on uh
is on Twitter having spats with people
having feuds people with with people
that we know he's having Public public
tantrums and this guy's like I mean you
I'm gonna Sue this person meanwhile he's
gonna Sue members of our audience even
other other lawyers other lawyers come
into the department you guys to sue me
uh let's see if we can get him to pursue
they uh they they come into the thread
and these other lawyers are like okay I
don't know what type of law this guy
practices but no the things that he's
claiming that he can sue people for are
not actually real and I guess this guy
has a history of this this is the guy
here right yeah yeah yeah
so I do anything about this Texas Paul
do you know anything about it yeah
here's the thing you know as a person
you you're limited in your contributions
packs can make more than can can even if
you're not coordinating a pack doing
something on your back if they loan you
money
something like that they have to act in
a usual standard business manner so if
if
Santos got a loan he's not making
payments on it that pack must send you
to collections to try to get that loan
paid back right they can't they can't
just hold that they can't just hold that
note right just because just because
you're not paying because yeah that
legally the FEC says that legally turns
into a campaign contribution
right because it's not alone it's a gift
because you're not requiring them to pay
it exactly any situation if you've got
somebody hosting your website and you
don't pay them in a normal fashion for
as anybody else in the business world
would pay somebody for hosting a website
that will become a gift to you
and the campaign contribution
it's just the way the law works
because the FEC can't can't determine
the difference between you never paying
your bill and them giving you a gift
right so in other words
um like um if the this John Ruiz here uh
who has a blue check mark because he uh
paid Elon eight bucks I'm not [ __ ]
you this is [ __ ] real right here he
paid eight lot eight Elon Musk eight
bucks a month to have his so if so if he
if he was running for office I am just I
mean it's a little scenario here and and
he didn't pay Elon B Elon kept his check
then it's a campaign contribution for
Milan you can't handle it
Caitlyn just reminded me of one of the
people that he uh threatened to Sue was
Thai because Ty wrote an article about
him and his dealings and these documents
and all this stuff it's pretty funny
like if you go through and you just find
this guy I'm sure you'll be able to look
up uh up the the back and forth and
again other lawyers were in there being
like you you don't know what are you
talking about you cannot sue for what
you claim you have nothing especially if
what they're talking about is true
he's not even blue checked he's not even
blue checked for he's not even blue
checked for being an attorney here's
he's even he's even going after uh dhara
which is she's a she's on Twitter
um because she retweeted something I
think is that why what yeah that's why I
turn you say that's why attorneys tell
you never if somebody says I'm gonna sue
you never worry about that ever ever
ever because
yeah because no attorney that knows
anything will ever announce to you I'm
gonna sue you no they just [ __ ] show
you right they actually find out you're
getting sued when the guy notch on your
door yes I have these documents for you
yeah are you so and so great you've been
served the other thing that's funny
about this is that uh he he said he had
sent Dara an email and dar responded
she's like I don't have any of my public
emails out there like I've scrubbed the
internet with that stuff so I don't know
who you emailed but it definitely wasn't
me and I don't have anything in my inbox
so keep trying here here he is here he
is um here he is responding to her of
course he's digging a hole like most
attorneys if it comes to Legal [ __ ]
that's the other thing an attorneys will
do is shut the [ __ ] up if an attorney if
if an attorney has a client that is
going to sue another person they tell
them shut the [ __ ] up don't say anything
about it public so never when an
attorney who's going to sue someone go
on a tirade on Twitter about how they're
gonna sue someone it's [ __ ]
ridiculous
um here's here's Dara and I look forward
to getting sued for checks notes
replying to a tweet
just totally owning this attorney at law
blue checked blue checked attorney at
law uh John Ruiz and he says make sure
you hire Ari because
um I don't want to get off on the weeds
in this but you keep talking about the
blue checks did you hear talking about
blue checks did you hear about the giant
dump cat turd took on Elon Musk
and I don't I don't that was beautiful
oh it's hilarious that was hilarious
he's like oh I'm being canceled by Elon
Musk and Elon Musk like responds to that
[ __ ]
Catherine says who the [ __ ] would want
to buy an electric car anyways
and Elon Musk is like excuse me
wait cat turd went against Elon Musk yes
oh yeah hang on hang on let me pull it
up we're past the second hour but this
is worth it
no no no hey hey we are here for Kevin
McCarthy losing
losing
um the first ballot in a hundred years
uh we're here for George Santos is a
[ __ ] fraud and we are here for cat
turd turning on Elon Musk that is I just
uh whenever they hold because I'm
following live on the house uh yeah
right now
um they haven't gone back to it's
everyone is just talking and whatnot so
keep in mind that the last vote took
roughly 45 minutes from to get through
from from the start of the call of the
vote to the end final vote so it took
about 45 minutes max 50 minutes so just
keep that in mind if you watch later on
today uh it'll probably take you less
than an hour could I mean I don't see it
going longer than that I think each time
it'll get quicker and quicker as they
decide who the final but roughly around
45 minutes is uh
is what the votes will take
I don't know who this person is but they
had a screen shot at that healing tweet
I just sent it to you but it's just
freaking hilarious because you know
remember cat turd was
yeah I mean remember captured is the
person who believes there was a
conspiracy with Nancy Pelosi holding her
phone and says look the screen is black
busted and everyone's like it's called a
proximity sensor well that's because
that's because the account is called cat
turd really are we [ __ ] it's it's
ridiculous that this is the right wing
newsmaker is canterd now here's here's
the um here's the image yeah I don't
know who this person is that sent this
tweet out to don't connect if they're
[ __ ] awful or something like that
don't connect me to them it was just the
first one that came off let's use the
actual screenshot I imagine cat turd and
and canterd tweets with its blue check
mark right yeah well that he paid for
right do you think he pays in in dirty
kitty litter or actual money
um cat turd says imagine believing
electric cars are good for the
environment and lamping and then Elon
Musk responds Elon Musk wait Elon Musk
is a cat turd simp that is where we're
at guy who owns Twitter
one of the first interactions that Elon
had coming back onto Twitter and we're
taking it over to be like oh yeah I will
personally look into your Shadow band
problem well and that's that's a little
bit of the cat turd drama here and I
don't mean to close on can't turds on
the show but it is some drama because
cat turd
um over the weekend was upset that he's
he's being Shadow banned or some again I
guess and and
um
you're not getting you're not getting
Shadow banned okay especially under Elon
Musk now the only problem is that well
it could be I mean like is there a lot
here I'll say this if you're on the
right you're not getting Shadow banned
okay those people have had their any
sort of any sort of search uh ban or
Shadow ban or other sort of like
filtering going on they definitely had
those things popped off and everyone is
is got like a modified Muffler on the
cargo
down the street it's annoying as [ __ ]
and it's loud and that's what's
happening but these people aren't being
suppressed in any way they're probably
as loud if not louder than they've ever
been
and they continue to complain about
these things and they're [ __ ] [ __ ]
um I I do I do want to bring up one more
story before we go um yeah I I don't
mean to end on canterd and then switch
to a serious note here but last night
during Monday Night Football
um I think it was in the first quarter I
was not watching the game
um I don't want to get his name wrong I
don't know football that well right now
um it is uh Hamill ham what's his name
what's the football players yeah Lamar
Hamlin uh Lamar Demar Handler uh Demar
Hamlin um he went for a tackle and um he
he got hit in the chest now the video
shows if you watch it a lot of people
aren't are saying don't show it online
um but I mean it is what it is it was on
live TV what are you gonna do yeah it
wasn't a dirty hit or anything like that
there's nothing it really wasn't even a
hard hit per se
um in that it didn't look that hard it
was [ __ ] hard but it wasn't unknown
in ordinary I mean now he stood up
almost immediately
um after the play and then um he he
looked like he was audible like he was
speaking and then
um he went lifeless uh his heart stopped
is what happened
um there was some sort of cardiac event
um there was a lot of speculation this
morning online and even in the media
about what kind of cardiac I meant it
could be
um there are a few events that it could
possibly be but of course these [ __ ]
[ __ ] boxes on the right Charlie Kirk is
one of them yes well that's why I wanted
to bring this up because Charlie Kirk is
a [ __ ] bag here
um now I get they did um CPR [ __ ] I hate
that guy talks to our kids [ __ ] yeah
yeah well then that could be a whole
another 15 minutes but um on the field
they did CPR the medical staff did CPR
and apparently they and they defibed him
right there on the field to try to keep
him alive because now his heart was not
beating so they were trying everything
they could that's not exactly true I
don't mean to correct you but that's not
he went into afib if like if every once
in a while in the major leagues you'll
see somebody get hit with a baseball and
they'll go down
your heart the upper left ventricle I
believe it is we'll go into afib from
the sh from the hit and you're not
pumping blood your heart's just freaking
out and quivering so they defibrillated
him to get his heart into a regular
rhythm again right because it went out
of it went out of a crazy yeah well yeah
they did CPR and they used the AED and I
think it was I think it was 10 minutes
they did it there on the field
um and of course surrounded by all the
players now the the most disgusting
thing I think that is the narrative here
is that first at first at the first
mention of this everyone seems to be
bringing up the game who gives a rat's
ass about the NFL or the [ __ ] game
really frankly
um if if the NFL wants to be responsible
here in the statement from them I
thought was [ __ ] gross I thought it
was [ __ ] gross the first thing they'd
talk about is postponing the game and
the last part of the statement is about
postponing the game they didn't give a
[ __ ] about anything but their [ __ ]
profits and and that that really is the
story here and there and the reason why
a lot of these these professional
athletes especially in professional
football are ending their careers on
their own early because they are not
being protected they just aren't and and
this may be another example of that me
and Gabe were chatting about it last
night that you know
um we haven't known about CTE that long
in comparison to how long professional
football has been going on and these
guys have had CTE but the equipment has
changed over time and they're still
changing the equipment which makes it
easier for these guys to to injure each
other uh in the game and really I'm a
fan of football I've been a fan of
American football as as if we have
people around the world watching
um for a long time I like college
football uh it's probably my favorite
over professional football but I'll tell
you there these kids are starting
earlier hitting
um with this type of equipment hitting
harder being trained to hit harder
um I I actually believe and and I know
this is going to piss a lot of people
off but the game has change these these
these players are going to be injured
they're going to continue to get these
injuries and I know this is this is some
kind of anomaly where he was hit with
his heart and the Rhythm but I'm telling
you I'm telling you folks if you want
football the game has to change because
we can't have these professional
athletes giving away their their two or
three years and their entire and that's
that's even that's right and the other
the big thing there you have to remember
is that's even assuming those players
have made it into the NFL you're not
talking about the four years during or
you know uh let's say four years before
high school four years into High School
four years in college I mean just last
year this is what I was telling Tony
last night I was like just last year
were players you know the Supreme Court
decision to say yes players should be
paid right we have to remember that
colleges the Monopoly that is college
sports especially college football is
able to make money hand over fist on top
of athletes and their health and
well-being just to run them into the
ground and that's assuming sometimes for
up to five years depending on their
registered yeah exactly so then you've
got that and then that's assuming that
okay let's go into the NFL
and
at that point now you've got someone who
wasn't paid for four years breaking down
bones knees shoulders wrists like what
have you to then hope they're in okay
condition to go into the NFL and be
recruited which again is a very small
percentage of a large population of
people who are actually playing so it's
one of those things it's like even if
you get in the NFL that's again that's a
small group of another small group of
people that you know weren't injured
weren't hurt but again just making sure
that somebody gets compensated at some
point for potentially the lifelong
injuries or health problems that they
experience during one of those periods
that they were playing you know well and
if we want this type of if we want this
type of enroutine I'm going to give you
a chance here at Texas Bob we want this
type of entertainment to continue
um High School football college football
uh professional football we have we have
to as fans I believe
um have have the the health and
well-being of these players in mind and
this game especially the expectation of
the game has to change
um years ago they didn't actually throw
the football I don't know if anyone
knows this but they did not they did not
throw the football
um and the game changed and every
everyone was okay with it it can change
again it is not something that we are we
are not we can't do well on that note
both you and Gabe are saying I just want
to continue on with it yeah the game has
changed it has changed
if you had people playing the way they
did like you know Franco Harris just
passed away he was I love that guy I had
a poster of him over my bed kneeling
with his hand on his helmet his nose is
ripped I mean because it's just he they
used to be brutal about gouging and
everything you know but they weren't as
big strong and fast as they are today
the science that's going into these
people and what Gabe was saying to
expand on what Gabe was saying about you
know you get the Tighter and Tighter
pool until you get to the pros the pros
are literally the best of the best in
every position and they are physically
these players are as physically strong
and fast and agile as any human being
can become so you take a look at this
hit it was not an extraordinary hit it
was just it caught him in the left side
of his chest
with a shoulder it wasn't dirty it
wasn't wrong it's a hit that's repeated
over and over and over again and
actually and he initially he initiated
the hit because he was tackling the
tackling yeah right yeah and and you're
right the game does has to change but
it's got to change financially there
needs to be a fund established that both
the players contribute to and this
league contributes to for people that
who are injured that that lose their
career early can tap into to have a a
life afterwards you know I mean this may
very well in this young man's career at
24. right
what now and and you know um that being
the point too I we see a lot of uh
players leaving the NFL in certain
positions where they are at risk of
getting hit numerous times over and over
and over and not wanting to give away
their entire life
um or the the remainder of their life to
some of these injuries that aren't seen
that you do not see it's invisible
injuries that that aren't but that
aren't apparent the best of the best
will tell you that's why they pay us
they will they will tell you that's what
those paychecks are for it's it's coarse
it's hard it's harsh to say but it's the
truth these guys go into the league
knowing the average person stays in the
league two years two
the vast majority of people fall out of
the league immediately in the first six
months or so they're not big enough fast
enough strong enough they end up going
to a practice team they end up going to
play in Canada or Europe or someplace
like that and you never hear from you
from them again you know but but the
ones that do stay look at JJ what that
is a young man right he is a young man
and he his his football career is over
now he's a big pretty some [ __ ] he will
end up on camera he's well spoken he
will end up on camera with a microphone
in his hand
but talk about what what Gabe was saying
earlier about the pool shrinking you
know we cannot have 53 men from every
Squad becoming commentators there's just
not room for him yeah right
you know so we have you're right Tony
you're absolutely right financially we
there has to be a change I don't think
physically you can stop this I mean if
he had an extra inch of padding on his
chest maybe I don't know well I I again
I know it's an anomaly but it only
points out the fact that the NFL
um that they have they have no
compassion for their players I know I
know they said in their statement they
were in communication with the players
union and [ __ ] like that but their
number one Focus was rather that [ __ ]
game was postponed or not and that that
game didn't matter a shit's bit of
difference in the moment or right now or
tomorrow or the next day as that guy
fights for his [ __ ] life as he fights
for his life he he did it happened on
the football field on live TV their
their immediate reaction should have
been postponed the game to hell with the
game let's make sure this this [ __ ]
player is alive when this when when this
Stadium empties and that should have
been their focus and and that just again
we live in a capitalist Society though
and profit margins are the number one
[ __ ] focus and Roger Goodell's Focus
was how is this going to affect our
profit margin is it going to hurt our
bottom line or is it going to help us
how are we going to make this help us
and that's the sick part about that's
the sick part about some of these
um how these athletes are treated
um and then again it's entertainment but
at what expense and one expense of
theirs so you know as a fan you know you
have to consider this that that the
people that you're watching entertain
you they're [ __ ] humans they got
family they got they got goals they got
lives I mean these are people these are
real [ __ ] people they're just not
avatars for your enjoyment
um so so keep that in mind when you're
considering and doing commentary about
the [ __ ] game rather you're gonna do
the really stupid thing about vaccines
or or you're going to talk about how
much of this this guy was a wimp or some
[ __ ] like that like this guy didn't play
right or something apparently this guy's
one of the best players from pitt
um he was in Pittsburgh and um I'm gonna
go to uh real quick to the house floor
or
I'm here I just sent you a link to as it
expands on what you were talking about
and what the NFL was thinking uh that's
from Skip Bayless if you if you follow
football you know who Skip Bayless is
and you just horrific take on
Devin m
M here is their official account it
looks like they're gonna go to a um
looks like they're going to go to uh the
second balance
Jim Jordan received six in the face
[Music]
has received one
nothing honorable about Lee zeldon
[Applause]
received a majority of the whole number
of votes cast by surname a speaker has
not been elected
following the procedure used by the
house in 1923 and recorded in Canon's
precedence volume 6 section 24 the clerk
is prepared to direct the reading clerk
to call a role anew
for what purpose does the gentleman from
Ohio seek recognition all right so
nominee Kevin McCarthy for Speaker of
the House
see I told you earlier that uh Jim
Jordan was going to be
um whipping votes here and that's that's
what Kevin McCarthy and Jim Jordan were
up to
for are you listening this is
this is McCarthy
um so he's basically giving trying to
give his six votes uh to McCarthy here
yeah and that's going to take the win
out of Matt gate sales and the whole
Andy big thing right there
the gentleman is recognized
that's right thank you madam clerk um
I think we have three objectives this
Congress three fundamental things we
have to get done laptop laptop laptop
pass the bills that fix the problems
we have a border that is we created the
problems and we're gonna pass the bills
that fix the problems they won't even
vote for the bills that they say the
problems are get the [ __ ] out of here
record debt and a government that has
been weaponized against we the people
against the very people everyone's
worried about George Santos being a liar
what the [ __ ] you're worried about Jared
Santos be the line you get this guy
lying his ass off
and I hope my Democrat colleagues will
join me no they're not going to join you
in voting for Kevin McCarthy you fool
and if they don't and if Chuck Schumer
says no we're not going to take up that
legislation that we pass and if Joe
Biden won't sign it so be it hey Jim
Jordan realizes how our government works
second second we can never ever let a
bill like the one that passed 12 days
ago 1.7 trillion dollars we can never
ever let that kind of legislation pass
again they never want to pass
legislation to help the American people
you heard it from Jim Jordan right here
on the Tony Michaels podcast it looks
like Jim Jordan's gonna nominate Kevin
McCarthy we'll see if someone steps up
and nominates uh Andy Biggs if you want
to watch it go to C-SPAN watch the
continued coverage there
um I'm glad this happened on Tuesday
Texas ball for you to join us everyone
go file Texas Paul's YouTube channel on
YouTube just type in Texas Paul you
you'll find his YouTube channel go
follow him make sure to follow us here
on the Tony Michael's podcast you don't
want to miss a single episode of the
show Monday through Friday noon Eastern
11 Central 9 Pacific we're back on a
regular schedule no more holidays for
the foreseeable future you're gonna have
to listen to me five days a
[ __ ] week
that's right we're good are you are you
a hundred percent are you like I gotta
I'm I got a test today but I'm pretty
sure oh okay this weekend it was a very
very very very faint how's that
pregnancy test coming is it it's a very
very very uh strong positive all right
whoa what you're pregnant oh my God
rearing it right here breaking news all
right everybody
um stay tuned uh make sure to download
every single episode on Apple Spotify
Google thanks for joining us today on
our day back from our holiday break of
the New Year's I hope your New Years was
great
until tomorrow same time same place
Surf's Up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the Tony
Michaels podcast in your face commentary
of current events and political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them [ __ ] em
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn head ass Beacon